Okay, I had high holocyste 15.8 and went on methyl B12. It came down by points and then kind of plateaued.
An integrative doctor I am working with will be on
a two-week low-methiety diet, expecting this to drop by holocyste further instead it went up three points.
So I'm back to taking the methyl B12.
So I assume in this low-methiety diet you stopped the methyl B12
since limiting it to barely didn't bring down my holocyste.
What do you think is the best approach?
So, holocyste is an end product of the mithiety cycle.
Mithiety, let's call the mithiety cycle because mithiety was discovered as a participant of that cycle.
So, that doesn't just do mithiety.
So, folate pathway breaks down different things down into methyl tetrahedral folate goes into the mithiety cycle.
B12 is recycled through the MTR, the MTRR gene that goes up to mithiety and circles around to holocyste and it goes through the cyste cycle.
So, having excess homocysteed, the first thing you think of is you need more methyl groups to help support that loop.
So, obviously going on methyl groups for you did the trick, it brought it down into normal levels.
So, I would just stay on methyl groups and I don't think you have to necessarily worry about it.
That's about it plateauing. You may have some issues back up in through the cyste cycle too.
So, we might have to schedule a call with me.
I might have to take another look at your genetics and look at the cyste pathway to see if there's some blockage there that might be one of the issues as well.
My homocysteed is around nine. Can I take B12, B6 folate and trivethyl glycine or without the TMG?
Yeah, I mean, you can do anything you want to do. So, you know, this might need a specific visit with me. I have to look at what I already have you on.
I have to look deeper into your genetics as well and your lab work as well.
So, it's hard to just, I don't, I know we're trying to, to be as specific to you as possible to, with some of these questions, but it can be difficult when I.
Answer it as a group without getting into exactly your specific so apologize for.